as you may know but just to touch on
long now members have the first chance
to buy tickets to these talks like
tonight most of our talk sellout so we
appreciate all of you if you're a member
raise your hands got a lot of members in
the house thank you and thank you for
those who aren't think about becoming a
member members can also hi watch live on
online they're watching us right now
so thanks to members who are watching
all around the world live right now so
without any further ado we have a
wonderful talk for you tonight
Judy Weissman's book pressed for time is
on sale in the back and she will be
sticking around afterwards to sign it
and hang out and talk we'll have Q&A
after her talk but really I encourage
you to hang out afterwards whether
you're getting a book signed or not that
conversation that happens after the mic
is off can also be really fantastic so
without any further ado please join me
give a big round of applause for Judy
wise man I'm gonna tell you about this
book I've written on speed and
acceleration and when I was looking for
inspiration for this book I'm back to
where I am I actually went to the
Science Museum in London and I literally
happened upon the long now clock I took
a photo of it and next to it there was
this quote from Stuart brand and I and I
didn't know anything about this clock
and I just thought wow this is just the
most amazing project and it expresses
exactly my view which is about the
importance of objects and artifacts for
how we think about time and then in
preparation for giving this talk Michael
gave me Stewart brands book the clock of
the long now talking about the project
and
Stewart actually says exactly this that
the ambition and folly of the clock is
to reframe human endeavor
not with a thesis but with a thing the
clock is an instrument for thinking
about time in a different way now I'm a
sociologist of Science and Technology
and actually what Stewart is expressing
is exactly what we do in science and
technology studies in that we're very
interested in how we make machines and
then machines make us that we think
about machines is actually embodying our
culture and then this culture in turn
the values and assumptions of that
culture shapes up us and what I want to
do today then is very much focus on our
how our perceptions of time how we think
about time and made with and through the
various technologies that we've made
time technologies ok so let me just
begin I've been interested in clocks and
time as I said for decades and I was
brought up actually on Marxist labor
history and was very interested in the
role of clocks for the formation of
industrial capitalism how we have
started to think about labor as timed
labor and measured it with clocks and
how this kind of image actually sort of
summarizes to me 20th century timed
labor if you like but if you think about
assembly lines all of these timetables
they all rely on clock time they're all
about accurate time keeping and when I
teach my courses at the London School of
Economics and I still try and teach
social theory there which is very
difficult to do nowadays in the
contemporary university but I won't go
into that I teach at the London School
of Economics and the British Museum is
an easy-out war from there and I've
actually found this old curator of the
horology department who lives way down
in the interstices of the British Museum
and we get and I get and complete
thrilled going to the back you know
going inside the British Museum
the guy is down there in a room full of
clocks and watches and he puts on his
gloves for my students and pulls out
those amazing kind of drawers they have
full of thousands and thousands of
clocks and watches and hands them round
and so these students who initially said
all we've been to the British Museum we
didn't go because we you know all
riveted they absolutely love it they
send a card every year thanking him for
you know how i opening it has been and
what he one of the things he makes very
clear to them is that actually it was
only with the innovation of the pendulum
clock which we have over here on the
left-hand side that it's only when we
have the pendulum which becomes common
in the 18th century that actually people
start thinking about time in terms of
minutes and seconds that you get sort of
accurate timekeeping and what the
students come away with is that they've
never really thought about the fact that
you know for most of kind of earlier
periods of history people thought about
time in terms of necessary tasks and in
terms of seasons right not in terms of
minutes and seconds but this is actually
a very recent notion of time and it's
the one we have now internalized if you
like in the 20th century actually when I
was talking about this to John Markoff
he reminded me that in the the classic
book the soul of a new machine by Tracy
Kidder I don't know how many of you have
read that it was a classic for me when
it came out in 1980 and it's this iconic
book about a group of guys trying you
know computer scientists trying to kind
of innovate with this computer and at
the end of the at the end of the story
they're completely wiped out you know
they've just been working day and night
and whatever and and one of the guys
says at the end which has kind of much
cited as John reminded me he says
because he's had at the project later he
says I'm going to a commune in Vermont
and we'll deal with no unit of time
shorter than a season I'll deal with no
unit of time shorter than C which I
thought was fabulous actually so if we
had to describe our sense of time the
quintessential 20th century sense of
time that we have all modern temporality
I would describe it as linear
chronological clock time and it was
against that background but I got very
intrigued by all these debates about
time speeding up that we're living in
this incredibly fast time that there's
be trading there's be dating every
aspect of life is speeding up and that
we have more and more digital devices
and yet we seem to have less and less
time we're busier and busier and busier
and at the core of all these arguments
actually is the notion that somehow it's
digitalization it's digital devices that
are driving the speed of light but that
is profoundly kind of altered the tempo
and the texture of everyday life and
this claim actually is made in popular
discourse all the time now
I used to once buy all these books they
come out so often I've given up on
buying these books but they're all
bemoaning our current state of busyness
and distraction you know that because of
our phones we can't think anymore
we can't talk anymore we're all subject
to digital addiction and we can't even
sleep because of constant interruptions
and in all of these books even sherry
turkle's and I'm a great fan of sherry
turkle's earlier work actually she too
says that digital devices are killing
conversation you know alone together is
you know I think portrays that in the
title and the solution to these problems
is often a digital detox let's lock up
the machines go back to nature I mean I
don't know about you but I mean the
Guardian seems to weekly have some
journalist who tells us at length about
the fact that they manage to get off the
media for a whole week and they're going
to tell us about
experience and how enlightening and
amazing it was for them you know as if
this is still interesting and even even
Arianna Huffington had set up a company
called thrive Global that aims to turn
even sleep into a productivity tool and
if you sort of read her stuff one of the
products she's selling is a little it's
a little bed like this and you plug all
your machines into the bed and it's a
charger and you put it outside your
bedroom so that you know and then you
close the door and you can have a good
night's sleep now I must say when I
first read this I didn't realize what a
big market sleep apps were actually I
just thought this what's she doing but
actually it is a huge market and I know
from the gdt GTD getting things done
movement for example you know but one of
the things they advise is that you try
and sleep a little less and you can
sleep a little less if you're sleeping
really efficiently so the last thing
last thing you want to be as a sleep
slacker right so paradoxically as I say
the common solution to the busyness to
the hurry is to buy more and more
technologies just try and save time
whether it's self trackers calendars
Aleksey Sarah all these things that are
supposed to make our lives more
efficient so that we can save time and
particularly multitask I think there's a
lot of sales pitch about if we'll only
do 10 things at once really be efficient
and this is all about kind of time
management and what I try and do in my
book just in a sort of sentence is
really to try and kind of deconstruct
that paradox examine this paradox that
we somehow live with such a
schizophrenic attitude towards our
technologies that we seem to endlessly
vacillate between looking to the
technologies as the solution to problems
and thinking of them as a cause of all
of these problems of time pressure and
my basic argument in the book is that
this imperative of speed or time
I think as much hasn't got much deeper
roots than just I don't mean just but
much deeper roots the digital technology
but I think it's as much a cultural
artifact as it is a technological one
and I hope to sort of convince you of
that this evening now what I mean when I
say that is that I don't think of
technologies as neutral value-free
innocent tools that somehow drive
changes in society I very much think of
technologies as inherently social this
is what we do in the sociology of
science and technologies we say that
technologies are social that their
crystallization of society that you can
read a lot about the society from those
technologies and of course this wouldn't
be news to an archaeologist right I mean
archaeologists find objects they talk
about it as material culture and they
think and I've got some people who know
a lot about this here and they think of
course they from these objects they can
tell a lot about the society you know
which produced them and that's exactly
what we try and do in science and
technology studies ok so what are the
cultural values that I think are baked
into our technologies what kind of
temporal orientation or philosophy of
time do these technologies reflect and
of course I want to start with saying a
few words about the hyper productive
work culture of Silicon Valley where
after all much design takes place this
is from Facebook's famous little red
book that you'll all kind of remember
and I think it sums up very well the
kind of ethos of a lot of these
companies the quicks shall inherit the
earth it's all about speed fast is
better than slow I mean you know yes
it's all I think valorising speed and
living in the fast lane
rather than anything else and I was once
when I was in the airport I actually
picked up as one does in the airport
books like how Google works how can you
resist picking up Schmidt and
Rosenberg's book and I opened
this book and I found that there's a
section in this book literally called
overworked in a good way
overworked in a good way and here they
actually say that work-life balance
policies are actually insulting to
employees that they want to create a
culture where there's always far too
many things to do and where you only
rest so that you can be even better to
get back to work
and I was then at a Tim O'Reilly food
camp actually in the Ottoman ER and a
couple of guys were telling me and I'm
sure you all know about this but it was
news to me and maybe that's the you know
what the news is that it was news to me
they said to me you know there's a real
thing here in the valley about
double-speed watching and speed
listening that to audiobooks to podcast
they said to me lots of people will not
even go to a real live event because
they've conditions themselves that it
feels really slow so I hope that this
hour isn't gonna feel slow to you that
you don't wish you were home on the
double speed you know and they
demonstrated this to me and show me that
actually they you know that the sound is
very good that you can actually kind of
technically do this but anyway I said
naively I said well why are people doing
this double speed and they said to me as
always as you know I always feel like
I'm looking a bit naive at this point
they said to me well so you can consume
more content get more done faster
to save time fit more in or avoid
wasting time in particular people get
very sensitive they told me about
wasting their time and I have to tell
you that this problem is a very acute
problem here before I came to cast for
this year I was up in the way up in the
Austrian Alps at a kind of summer school
for European from students all over
Europe actually and I met this wonderful
philosopher Owen Flanagan who works on
anger and the causes of anger and
particularly on cross
cultural he's terrifically good at huge
cross-cultural studies of where you know
what are the causes of anger in
different cultures and he came up to me
after my talk and he said I've really
got to tell you that what I found is
that especially for Americans he said
somebody wasting my time is the major
cause and reason for anger particularly
for Americans he said this is the sort
of worse thing and actually there's
quite a lot of academic research that
confirms this and there's a terrific
young guy in Berkeley who did a who
wrote a PhD where he compared what he
calls the work narrative of managers and
professionals in the US and France and
Norway a few years ago and he found that
actually there still was a distinction I
think less and less I have to say but
there still was quite a distinction and
that he said that the Europeans actually
still were rather suspicious of people
who were working conspicuously long
hours he said but to quote Americans he
said in his in you know the the
interviews he did and they were very
extensive actually do not associate
happiness dividends with leisure as
Europeans do Americans seemed to derive
satisfaction simply from working long
hours these scripts reflect a culture
that values over achievement in itself
and has a long-standing moral aversion
to idleness that's what really struck me
a moral aversion to idleness now why do
I care that optimizing time is so highly
valued that this is the quintessential
experience of modernity well I have to
tell you that I'm one of those people in
the 80s and I taught courses on chips
and the micro like micro electronic
revolution in the 80s I thought actually
that this technology was going to
liberate us and free us to work much
less and I had always been a great fan
of Maynard Keynes as writing in the
1930s which was that with technology you
know with advances in productivity that
we would be heading towards three
I work a day you know the 15-hour week
and that this is the direction we were
kind of going in absolutely and
crucially and this is crucial that this
free time would be distributed equally
right that actually a just society would
guarantee all citizens a fair share of
free time and free time to do whatever
they wanted we weren't going to
stipulate this we whatever we wanted and
this is an old labor poster I know but
I'm still very fond of it a 19th century
labor movement slogan and while I
disagree with the eight hours work it's
far too much right what I really like
about it is the eight hours for what we
will and you can see the image there is
not about optimizing time right it's
actually really a lovely image I think
of doing what you want with your time
actually really talking thinking about
free time and that's why I'm that's sort
of my theme this evening okay now as a
early feminist as I you know we're now
called second wave feminists this is
I've lived through now being a
historical relic of that movement I
noticed that women had less free time
than men and I and that all of the labor
saving devices that we were sold in you
know washing machines and dishwashers
and all these things somehow hadn't
eliminated housework let alone cause the
women's movement I mean you're probably
too young to remember that was literally
said at the time that these appliances
so had eliminated work that all these
housewives had nothing left to do and so
they caused the women's movement and
this was seriously out of boredom right
so I've done a lot of research on
household technology then let me tell
you that technology's rarely simply save
time that what you find is that you know
what technologies do new technologies is
that they actually change the meanings
of tasks they change standards you start
washing clothes you light clothes and
dark clothes you start sending more
emails that all of the
these technologies historically we know
that there isn't a very simple
connection between saving time and
introducing new technologies and I think
at the core of this problem really is
the way we think about time the time is
somehow viewed as a resource that can be
measured mastered according to the
engineering logic of efficiency and
optimized optimization that that's
really how we think about time and we
don't actually step back and think that
there's about the fact that there's a
lot of things we don't want to do faster
actually we don't want to accelerate
everything and you only have to think
for a moment about parenting right
there's a moral panic about you know
iPhones and parenting and you know
nobody's speaking anymore that phones a
destroying conversation but actually if
you look at the data and this is what we
do our social scientists we actually
look at time use data in great detail to
see really what people are doing over
long periods of time you find that
mothers and fathers are actually
spending more time with children than
they ever have before that we are
actually living in a period of intensive
Parenthood and we know from these
statistics that mothers and fathers are
actually spending more time talking and
playing with kids than they did 50 years
ago you know that it isn't the story of
this moral panic at all but if you think
about it this kind of family or caring
time encompasses a lot of different
activities and a lot of emotions and
it's about talking and listening and
emotional nurturing it's about a lot of
tasks that are very fragmented that are
woven into other processes and really
have nothing to do with efficiency and
actually a lot of giving care involves
slowness being their forms of intimacy
that can't be automated and so I think
this distinctive kind of temporal
consciousness if you like which is fluid
and open-ended and slow just does not
fit with the rigid clock
time of machines you know that there's a
real disjunction between these different
kinds of temporality a few years ago I
was in Barcelona
speaking at a Contemporary Arts Center
there's a wonderful art center called
CCC B that has fabulous exhibitions and
they were doing an exhibition on cyborgs
and human machines and you know the
things that are on all over the place
nowadays and it just happened that this
conference coincided with the annual
World mobile phone conference that they
have every year in Barcelona maybe some
of you go to that you do you do go to
that anyway it's on it's a huge thing in
Barcelona or actually the people there
told me that it's a huge thing for the
economy in Barcelona and whatever and I
was switching between these two
conferences and I have to say that the
vibe was so different in these two
conferences I just thought I'd tell you
about this right so I took an image in
the from the Art Center and a woman
artist had done this and I really loved
it actually in fact when I went to look
at it in preparation for this talk I
noticed that she'd actually called it
optimization of parenting which i think
is kind of weird given my theme but she
wonders about whether this will affect
her child and then she says suggesting a
robot take over some parental tasks is a
provocation that highlights the struggle
mothers have and she says you know
mother artists artists that mothers have
with work/life balance and I have to say
while I really sort of liked it it's a
B&B a huge engineering company you know
I really liked it is because it's an old
technology actually prams were invented
over 300 years ago so it's an old
technology it's a simple technology it
has a universal sort of task and I think
it kind of highlights how much we have
this fixation always on the new on the
latest that we don't actually think
enough about tech Trude and tried kind
of technologies that still functions
still function incredibly well
and this was just an image I took from
the mobile phone conference you know the
mobile phone conference that every bit
of high tech staff had these boards
everywhere flicking away you know
flashing away at one where everyone went
and as you can see the whole pitch
actually here is speed it's always kind
of speed okay so it's this fixation with
the kind of new and speed that has led
me to carry out a little bit of research
while I'm here at the Center for
behavioral sciences on electronic
calendars so just in this last bit of
the talk I just want to very briefly
tell you some things I've started to
think about in terms of calendars you
may think the first question is why why
study electronic calendars why did you
choose that of all things let me tell
you why I chose it for a start
I'm sure you've all got mobile phones
with you and that in those mobile phones
actually you have got calendars and that
you're carrying them around with you
that your phone actually is with you all
the time and giving you a sense of time
and it's not like it's it's not like in
all of human history you've been walking
around with this accurate timepiece with
you but also I have to say I arrive here
you know ice from from London I arrive
here at a moment where artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
Big Data are all the rage you know these
are the ideas that everyone is talking
about in terms of what the future is
going to look like what's going to make
the future and I even read in the LA
Times that we live in the age of the
algorithm you know this is defining our
current period and then I go to a
conference in Washington with high-level
CEOs it's a conference on the future of
work the end of work and automation I go
to these conference I can't tell you how
often I go to these conferences where we
discuss this topic and I could say a lot
about that topic but anyway I sit down
at a table with these guys and and I
being you know giving my talk and they
all of them immediately get out there
you know get out their phones and show
me their calendars and they say to me
we've really got to tell you the the big
problem in Silicon Valley is a shortage
of time and we think one of the
solutions is to automate to keep
automating everything including these
calendars that these will help solve the
problem
and what I was found particularly
interesting with the idea that somehow
artificial intelligence was going to
turn these calendars into intelligent
scheduling assistants there were going
to do more and more things automatically
and we'll get to know us so well that
that that its algorithms will be able to
give us advice on how to use our time
wisely so here we have a mundane every
everyday instance where machine learning
is being employed to solve the
existential problem in the words of one
designer how best to organize the time
of our lives
now that's some aspiration right for
this technology I thought to myself so
how might these electronic calendars be
affecting how we think about time
shaping how we think about time and what
might they say about our fixation with
artificial intelligence these are the
sort of things I'm now thinking about
now calendars like prams are a very very
old technology they go back all of human
history are one of the first meaning
making devices and I've read that
actually the first item ever printed by
the Gutenberg press was a calendar an
almanac a program of future events and a
record of past events each assigned to a
day or year but what's uniquely modern
is the idea of a schedule a schedule at
a microscopic level and if you'll excuse
me I know this is my only sort of text
but I wanted to put it up here this is
the most famous sociologist of time he's
an American he's written loads of books
on the year
the month and you know all of these
things historically and I think he puts
this better than anyone else really
where he's trying to capture what modern
temporality is and talks about schedules
as being uniquely modern because they
embed this economic utilitarian
philosophy of time he says it reflects
as well as promotes a quantitative view
of time which involves a definition of
time as an entity which is segmental
into various quantities of duration and
is countable and is measurable and he
goes on to say that shedding is actually
absolutely key to effective time
management because you develop a sense
of priorities and with these priorities
you dispense with any wasteful time
unnecessary time that you schedule
properly so that there isn't room for
wasted time for as the behavioral
psychologists write many articles about
the crime of procrastination this seems
to be the worst crime and psychologists
devote a lot of energy to teaching us
how not to just potter about which I
very much like doing I have to say so
just a point just a few points about
these calendars Michael very nicely made
me up a calendar here we try to worked
up a calendar it's not to be taken
seriously we just sort of played around
with what one of these calendars might
look like and I just want to make a few
points about it the first thing I want
to say is that that lots of the
designers I've spoken to who design
these calendars have spoken to me about
the fact that the paper calendar that
you have on your refrigerator at home in
the kitchen is still far superior to
this grid like calendar and they talked
to me about the fact that on a paper
calendar you can stick all sorts of
things on there you can have multiple
times multiple activities but it's a
much more flexible sense of time than
this linear quantity of time that you
get in a grid and that this
grid interface actually fragments time
breaks time up makes it harder for
longer-term thinking as one designer put
it to me I'm too polluted in my mind by
the calendaring system so it's hard for
me to imagine a different unit of
measurement that is not a half hour or
15 minutes we definitely think in terms
of the tools that we use and the other
conversation I had with them was that in
a lot of companies nowadays the default
for meetings is now half an hour that
that's become the standard meeting time
and that this very much frames what you
can do with a meeting how you think
about meeting chunks up things fragments
things and makes meetings very
functional and that a lot of them what
we talked about is the kind of social
glue the incidental things that keep
organizations going you know excluded by
this very regimented time actually one
of them said to me which I found very
amusing I have to say he said to me that
actually in my company you can hear
everybody's phones ping with a
notification at 20 minutes past the hour
and 10 minutes to the hour he said and
there's a slight because they're not on
exactly the same time it goes on for a
few seconds he says and thousands of
people are moving throughout the company
at that time and you know I found it so
ironic because it so reminds me of the
early 20th century rigid time in my
slide you know the kind of timekeeping
you think of this early 20th century
industrial time rather than the kind of
time you have in the latest corporations
so of course people tell me and I'm sure
you'll all know you all do this they
tell me about how they try and game the
system they try and gain their calendars
to make space for the contingencies of
real life because real life actually
doesn't fit into this flat time that
real life is full of multiple times
modulated times differentiated time
and qualitative time right and that
these calendars can only deal with
qualitative time so in other words as
lots of very important things
like caring that can't actually be
rendered or represented in these
calendars on the other hand and I think
this is kind of equally important and
it's the kind of flipside if you like
all these tracking devices and these
calendars make visible lots of things
that weren't visible before like your
pottering around that there are these
new forms of knowledge that are
presented to us by these technologies
that are being fed into these algorithms
and given this I really worry about this
project of turning calendars into
intelligent personal assistants that
will have a relationship with us rather
like a coach the head of UK Samson said
last week talking about his phones he
says your phone will be your concierge
your slave your concierge oh this was
wonderful your servant you know and the
idea here is the time really can be
managed more intelligently by machines
than it can by us I keep wanting to say
left to our own devices I'm trying you
know
left to ourselves right that we're not
only willing but we positively seem to
want to hand over the our the a our
agency and responsibilities to machines
that will have these machines nudging us
to make better decisions to giving us
advice about when to go to the gym when
to do other things that you know this
that rather than having friends
encouraging us to do things we will now
have software encouraging us to do
things as one programmer and said to me
from one of these big calendar companies
that I won't name but it's the one most
used she said to me AI can learn your
behaviors so you aren't the one having
to make decisions now you want now you
won't forget to buy a present for your
kids birthday party calendar is
always there whispering in my ear what
to do next now you know not an image
that I am very keen on okay so just to
conclude don't get me wrong whenever I
give talks on technology somehow it's
very easy if one has a kind of critical
stat about technology it's very easy to
be seen as addy technology being
nostalgic for less digitized times I
want to say clearly that is not me I
love my digital devices I mean I've
spent a lifetime working on science and
technology because I think these things
are amazing I wouldn't do that if I just
tried to diss them but what I do want to
sort of stress I'm at the end is that I
think it's a mistake that so much
innovation actually glorifies speed
glorifies optimizing time and cramming
more and more into each passing hour
that we're building technologies for
this hyper busy life without ever
stepping back and asking what what do we
want to save time for why are we in such
a rush to do all these things rather
than thinking about what do we want to
save time for and I really think that
this requires long-term thinking which
is why I am so so keen on the clock I
have to say in sociology we talk a lot
about this concept of present ism or
that we live in a culture of immediacy
and what we mean by that is that somehow
our time horizons have been shortened
that we do not have a lot of interest or
respect for the past or the future that
we live in very sort of contracted time
and that's what that's why I want to end
really with brand saying in a world of
hurry the clock is a patience machine
because I think it really embodies a
very different ethos of thinking about
time and I really hope that it can
provoke fresh thinking about valuing
different kinds of time in different
ways and also a new thinking about what
technologies we could design to support
a different kind of temporal
philosophy a different temporal order
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and Joe do you want to actually
help out with with the micro beer so
yeah we're gonna be taking your
questions thank you for for that
wonderful talk I have to say you know it
at the beginning of long now Danny
Hillis one of our our three founders who
had this initial idea of this big clock
the clock that would tick once a year
before he he had that idea his career
had been making some of the first super
computers and so I had to say that when
I first started hearing about your work
and we were talking about you speaking
it reminded me because I think he
literally said and Xander could check me
on this but I think he said he that
Danny had had spent enough time kind of
speeding the world up and he wanted to
kind of reflect on that and and maybe
help slow it down or at least you know
balance against that sped up sort of
feeling so you're you're working this
this year at casbahs at Stanford and you
are really embedded in this technology
industry I don't know that you've you
know in that same sort of way have been
in this culture certainly there hasn't
been I don't think a technology making
culture like Silicon Valley's even at
this moment you have history of Silicon
Valley what is that like going into the
into the into the Machine the center of
it what you expect is it is it what you
expected has it been
has it been really revelatory is what
you is it oh this is exactly what I
thought it would be like what's been
like it's it's an extreme version of
what I thought and I have been you know
I mean I was so intrigued with those
guys talking about
you know speed watching and you know the
whole the whole thing and I mean you
know perhaps is it kind of important to
say that that I'm very aware that it's a
very specific culture and perhaps it's
important at this moment to say that I
am you know what I talk about in the
book and what's very important to say is
that we're living in a society of huge
inequality and we're at one end here and
certainly a lot of people are kind of
very busy and stressed because they're
doing multiple jobs and not well-paid
jobs you know and that the temporality
of the uber drivers and that and
TaskRabbit
and the I mean you know one of the
things I watch from my flat in Stanford
actually is an army of people come in
the day to service people I mean I've
never sort of been in a flat where I
watch the dry cleaning ban and the blow
leaves and I mean actually my sort of if
you like the sound I'm gonna take back
with me to London is of the blowers you
know the leaf blowers right because I
mean this is just the you know so that
the there's huge amounts of servicing
going on and actually a colleague of
mine wrote a book about time some years
ago where she talks about taxi drivers I
think in Toronto or somewhere and talked
about the fact that actually a lot of
these taxi drivers are always kind of on
call a bit like the lyft drivers to
enable us to live a fast life right so
that there are classes of people whose
lives are devoted to enabling the speed
of our lives so you know I'm looking at
one end here which is the sped up life
as opposed to examining the way in which
we construct it which is a which is on
the basis of lots of other people's
labor if you like who are also speeding
but for very different reasons
and and the the title of the your talk
is the time poverty amidst digital
abundance so is time party if poverty is
that is that mostly a perceptual thing I
mean is that I don't know how much that
is actually a term of art or just a coin
edge of yours but you know is is it more
would you say a trick we're playing on
ourselves or is it also as you're just
saying sort of different populations
that are having different jobs because
certainly the person who's worked in
three jobs
has a different kind of time powerfully
than the person who just has that
calendar but I mean I think here
particularly what's very strong is the
kind of culture of busyness I mean I was
lucky enough to do a radio interview
with William Gibson once on BBC radio
when his most recent book had come out
it was a kind of couple of years ago you
know the science fiction writer and he
said to me you know actually saying
you're incredibly busy now is just
saying you're incredibly rich but that's
you know that that's the kind of
equivalent now and I mean I've had
people say to me at some of my talks I
mean you know colleague of mine in
Cambridge actually I've known for years
said to me you know if I go back to my
office now and there are no emails I'll
feel like a loser
I feel like a failure you know but this
is so much a measure of kind of our
sense of kind of self and who we are and
our importance and our status that it's
very hard to deconstruct you know that
it's that culture actually of you know
and anything I have to say that when I
you know first came to America and I'm
like 30 years ago I have to say when I
was you know I think I my first job was
in Edinburgh I remember sort of various
people said to me you know when you get
to America all those American academics
they're all gonna tell you that they're
incredibly busy you've just got to be
prepared for this you know that this is
part of that you know it's just part of
the you know what's culturally valued I
think and that I think makes leisure
such an undervalued activity and Joe are
you you've got great we'll take we'll
take it I've been yeah but we'll take it
to you the pleasure from the audience go
ahead um earlier you showed all the
covers of those books that blame the
technology
lack of time and I'm curious at the end
of the day what you think I mean I think
it's both right in that I do think work
in transportation you know the notion
that you should be at work very long
hours in a lot of these companies but
also if you're using some of these
online services where you have to be you
know if you're working through an online
app work or one of these things you know
there's lots of ways in which work now
is even more demanding of our attention
and having to be online but having said
that it's not that I think the
technologies are not important as well
and of course I'm very aware and
particularly at this moment in time the
technologies are designed to be
addictive and that a lot of the best
behavioral psychologists are employed
precisely to make these technologies as
addictive as possible and I'm very
sympathetic to campaigns like you know
Tristan Harris's but that's kind of
raising awareness about these features
of the technology themselves so I think
you know I think both things I just sort
of argue against this very simple notion
that somehow this hurriedness came about
when we got the iPhone or something
right so you know you go back and read
the Tracy Kidder book from 1980
it's absolutely could have been written
yesterday in terms of the culture of
this tech high tech organization and
these guys working 24/7 and competing
and you know so I just think it's it's
good to have a bit of perspective on on
speed not being a new phenomenon and
something that runs counter that I
recall I think from a unimagine it's
night but the runs counter that the
busier are the the B and the the
efficiency and benefit of the calendar
system that a lot of the executives kind
of the busiest people actually have an
assistant so they're not actually
engaging with their calendar at all I
think I've seen that happen as well is
that that's what you found is that
that's from
absolutely and everyone dreams I mean a
friend of mine who works in another huge
company you know just dreams are being
promoted to the next level because at
the next level you get a human personal
assistant you know and I mean I think
there's a you know it is it's just
putting more and more work on us on you
know and of course there's nothing like
a yeah so I mean very senior people of
course I've got people to do that I mean
one thing I came across which I thought
was very funny was the net was trying to
kind of you know it's Carly trying to
train people into thinking that really
these things automate and I discovered
with one of these systems that you
thought it was a digital assistant that
was making your appointments but
actually under that were all these
people who were actually doing the work
but it was made to look like look like
that so you know I think there's a lot
of complicated things going on with
trying to get us used to various forms
of kind of automation well there's a
weird sort of like take on the John
Henry and the steam shovel story there
or something where like you know the
that the calendar system is better than
that but ultimately the human can beat
the calendar when they've said to me
that I should I think it was Mitch Kapur
he said to me well the best thing would
be to have a personal assistant with a
fantastically sophisticated talent you
know if you could have two both those
things working together that would be
fantastic
yeah and and it's interesting with with
the time that you have spent now through
the evolution of technology as you've
been studying it and looking at people
interacting with it because that reminds
me of earlier times when like the very
complicated typewriter the very
complicated copier machine and
incredible things could happen with it
but no one was taking the time to read
the manual or understood how to work
with the interface and so you did have a
probably lower certainly lower paid
person who was your interpreter your
your guide to that technology so that I
wonder it seems like that pattern in
some ways has happened before are there
other things that you see where as you
get especially now closer to this but no
I was just thinking you know brand has a
line in the book about technologies what
doesn't work properly yet something
like that isn't it that that's how
that's how we think about what
technology actually is you know yeah
right so we don't think of prams we
don't think of all these technologies of
everyday life as even as even
technologies well one of those lines is
that it's it's and I'll look at sander
again probably but anything that's
invented before you were born is after
you're born into the technology I mean
one of the earliest things I mean I have
to say one of the earliest things as I
did as a feminist working on technology
and I've got a book decades ago and you
know about these things
was precisely to think about how we
think of what technology is you know and
that I used to think technologies were
things that were in car factories and
someone once said to me what about the
telephone or the washing machine or you
know that actually our very definition
of technology is gendered as well in
terms of you know what we think
technology is and can I just lab rate
just for what I mean you know and I was
very struck by the fact that kind of in
London its kind of in actually embedded
in the museum so if you happen to go to
London which I'm sure you do and you
know on one side of the road is the
Science Museum and on literally on
exhibition street on the other side of
the road is the Victoria and Albert
which has got in it tapestry and all of
these other kind of furniture arts and
crafts right and I actually said to the
director of the science museum you know
and when I met him I said geez this is
you know very interesting once on one
side of you know ones on the other sort
of thing and I said this is kind of a
rather gendered thing historically that
arts and crafts of thought offers set
not science and over here we've got the
spaceships and all of that
and he smiled and said yes and I have to
tell you he said you know that in terms
of who goes to these museums they you
know a lot more women go to the
Victorian Albert then go to the Science
Museum and that that many of the women
who go to the Science Museum go as
mothers with their kids you know so it's
like instantiated in the buildings and
still you know this historical you know
because it's only a few centuries all
this definition of what take what
what's technology and what isn't gets
instantiated in buildings and then
effects kind of the audience's that kind
of consume these things well I'm happy
to say that Victorian Albert has been
covering the Whole Earth Catalog and the
other along now related right so so
hopefully we're helping to balance some
of those things out and we're gonna get
another question for the audience
there's a comment from the stream
actually that my comment that we should
we yeah yeah so livestream folks I send
your questions in to please no just just
saying that don't we could we turn over
all our data to Cambridge analytics and
bacon take care of our scheduling for us
will be well covered right was there I
was alluding to that indirectly yes
somebody did tell me about doing a
design exercise of trying to include a
lot of family activities it was kind of
trying to do that and you've told me the
story about how Ansan won early one that
that weekends were smaller or something
the weekdays you see that I think you
see that on some analog calendars as
well that it's like lots of space to
fill in your events during the week and
then the weekends are small and there's
only like a couple things you can fit in
which is certainly doesn't figure
balanced eight-hour portions yeah I mean
it's not an easy thing to answer I have
to say that the designers all say to me
that they've really thought long and
hard about the grid interface you know
and that at the moment they can't think
of how to get away from that you know
that that seems to be the best
representation of time that they can
come up with and they know that it's
that it's a lack of imagination you know
but it's not like they you know I I ask
everyone this it's not like they say
I've never thought about they all say
yeah we've thought about this a lot
we've tried different things than we
still come back to this kind of
visualization I mean I think it's partly
to do with the visualization that goes
back to Philo factors and you know long
historical representation that is hard
to kind of get away from but you know I
wish I had an answer to that question
and what do you see and again you know
most of us I think are are here in the
Bay Area and so we're around a lot of
this particular culture coming from
London another busy place but as you're
as you're throughout research none of
the things that you're seeing are you
seeing differences in this feeling of
busyness this is the speed of life with
different demographic groups with
different people in different areas is
what can you tell us about sort of how
different populations feel because I
think there's a tendency you know in the
midst of the bay area to generalize you
know our experience to other places is
are there are there stories there that
would be an interesting tell I mean that
I think that's such a difficult question
actually I mean I worked for a while how
long ago it was just when Lehman
Brothers collapsed actually so that will
time it perfectly I was working in
London Business School for a while and
there was a lot of talk then about young
people at that time valuing time in
different kinds of ways and actually
choosing to work in companies that had
better flexible policies and work-life
policies and all of those things and you
hear much less about that now
interestingly and I think that is
probably because we're in a time where
there's a lot of unemployment and a lot
of insecurity and that you need to be in
better times where you can kind of
actively be making choices about kind of
different ways to live and the model
here seems to be but I mean you all know
more about this than me but it's like
you you just work intensively and burn
out and you hope that you know by the
time you burned out you can set up a
different kind of life which seems to
mean not a good model actually
let's you tell us a little bit more
about your book pressure time so this is
a few years back tell us a little bit
more about what's you know what's in
here is this is it largely the types of
things you're talking about here what's
what are what are you exploring in it
well less heaps of things in there I
mean I was apparently trying to locate
the discussion historically and so I was
very interested when I went back and
read about the kind of you know the
telegraph and the railway and Greenwich
Mean Time and you know I was just very
interested in how we got to this point
of a standardized time that we live by
but also you know when you reread
authors of that period you know priest
or whoever they all talked about you
know getting on a train and speed you
know and the speed and that they just
thought gosh they wouldn't be able to
see anything out the window cuz the
speed was so unprecedented and so I just
think it's very interesting historically
that we've had technological changes and
I think perhaps as dramatic as we're
living through now which is again an
argument I'd sort of like to make that
completely changed people's perceptions
of time and you know the Telegraph was
going all around the world and that you
know rather than I mean I remember sort
of reading this book once because I'm
sort of originally Australian write
about how you know people could have
died somewhere and the letter on the
boat would tell you know we take weeks
before it got to Australia and they'd be
reading about you know whatever it
happened back in Britain sort of thing
and how that changed with the Telegraph
and that that was such a dramatic sort
of change in terms of globalization and
you know the compression of space and
time and that I think it's very
important to think historically about
how dramatic those changes were compared
to the changes we've got today so that's
one thing I mean I could go on forever
Michael but I don't want to if this and
so so right now you're focused on
calendar software are there are there
questions like even from from from
audience of users right what's what's
your what's your sort of processed as
you're doing this work are you you're
talking to the designers are you talking
to
users what types of things are you still
sort of figuring out or still trying to
I've mainly been talking to designers
but I am interested generally in the
kind of algorithmic thinking if you like
how more and more big data is being fed
into various technologies and the kind
of effects that will have on us and I
mean if I can just sort of give an
example I mean again this isn't my work
but a colleague of mine in Oxford on
self tracking technologies that one of
the things Jean and Neff very much talks
about is how once you have this data you
then start measuring yourself against
the data you know so everyone does this
lunatic 10,000 steps a day and she says
in this book she has no idea where this
came from she has no idea if this is
kind of legitimate but you know that
once these you know that somehow these
tracking devices produce notions of
normal notions of standard one should
live up to and that one it's very easy
then to kind of think that you're a
failure that you're not managing to do
the steps that you're spending a lot of
time pottering round that you're not you
know optimizing and doing all these
things I mean even on the hill where I
work people are very concerned with
their productivity
you know who's writing a book and how
quickly and you know all of that and
it's quite and it's very hard actually
to have a sort of sense of self kind of
separate from that there's another
question over here there we go
[Music]
well if I can answer that as an angle I
have to say I was very excited by the
huge demonstrations that have have just
occurred and you know my hope is that
suddenly we have got young people
politicized you know that this will be
the moment like the Vietnam War was for
me I hate to say was the moment where
you know I became political and that
political consciousness lasted a
lifetime and so I think events like that
are actually much more kind of dramatic
in terms of people's political formation
and how they're going to live than their
current use of the phone you know I
guess suppress that comment there's a
certain article about a BuzzFeed about
about how a child uses BuzzFeed that
really sounds in it sorry he's as
opposed to use a snapchat it's almost
yeah and it really seems like they give
themselves a bunch of tasks to do at the
start of today that they've got to kind
of send a note to all of their friends
and modify an image for each of them and
do do all these things and in a way they
are so social media becomes its own the
your casual social media becomes its own
workload that you have to keep up are
you are you is your is your work at all
crossing over with with social media
things as well or just the calendar
and tell us so so you're at the London
School of Economics and political
science
yes so put that in contact sports cuz I
think I don't think everyone is familiar
with the we're talking a little bit
about the institution of it before and
you you mentioned also that social
theory was social science university so
the London School of Economics and
political science although it's always
shortened which we hate at the line of
school of economics or the LSE is a
social science university so we don't
have sort of computing and a medical
school and things we just have premier
economics history political science and
those things and we're very proud of the
fact that the institution was actually
originally formed by Fabian socialists
this was the origins of the Institute
and it's always been a kind of very
radical institution and so we are always
the ones who get it in the neck from the
press I mean if there's any left-wing
activity going on it is always the
London School of Economics and I'm proud
of that we get that in the Bay Area a
bit too oh one more question from the
audience there we go go there so first
off thanks for the radical feminism
I appreciate I was interested in your
talk I felt like you touched a little
bit on this sort of notion of like
better time usage being about progress
and kind of like advancing society and
one way that I see this reflected when I
travel or when I live in other countries
etc is the countries that have kind of a
slower sense of time often are
denigrated or even denigrate themselves
like they'll be like we have to speed up
our sense of time we have to be more on
says yes we want to match the
progress of the first world and I mean
in the way that I was taught to think
about this it's more sort of like okay
they have a different sense of time and
like especially like anthropology
circles it'll be like okay Mexico or
Africa observes polychronic time or
feels time in a different way and like
Switzerland in the u.s. it's monochronic
and it's just different more than like
better or worse but I think there's this
very keen idea that like monochronic
like up-to-the-minute like USA like
aggressively productive time is better
for getting things done and that means
that those societies will do better and
be happier and healthier and I guess I'm
just curious about how you would respond
to that both like both the charge that
societies that are more monochronic are
better and the fact that that idea sort
of influences these peoples note many
people's notions of themselves and
people's self-esteem in place in the
world I mean can I just say that I was
just yesterday actually at the triple a
what is it the Association of artificial
intelligence spring conference in
Stanford and there as happens so often
actually when I go to things you know
Europe is presented as very far behind
you know and the story that I get all
the time is you know poor old Europe you
know all that regulation you know
they're so far behind what's happening
here in kind of Silicon Valley and to
which I say actually you know democracy
and deliberation take a lot of time and
that actually the mechanisms that there
are in Europe now for having more
citizen engagement with the kind of
Science and Technology we've got the
directions in which it can go does take
time actually and I think we have to
kind of make the argument about whether
we're just going to get into this fast
and break things or whether we think
it's important to have much broader
participation in the kind of in our
futures I mean actually again you know
within science and technology stays we
talked about kind of socio-technical
imaginaries we
talk about how how does a culture think
about the future and articulate what the
future is and that you know Silicon
Valley at the moment is incredibly
powerful in having taken over this
discussion right that we don't have
discussions about political utopias like
we used to we just have discussions
about you know artificial intelligence
and what's going to be pretty you know
that's self-driving car or you know this
is what the future is going to be and we
need to recapture this conversation I
think away from this kind of tech
dominated future and think about our
social values and politics first and the
technology second and on that note I
think I am going to end my I have a long
now challenge coin as a small thing take
turn off your calendars stick around
take your time the the patient machine
is working
we've got copies of Judy's book in the
back whether you have a chance to get
one and have her sign it or you just
want to come up and ask her a few more
questions she's gonna be hanging out and
we hope you will too thanks again for
coming out to the interval tonight
[Applause]
[Music]